caroline on veut
était
[Musique]
dans mes seins coupés neige tombait n'a
pas été exaucé
ce que
ça dormi avec
info père noël est malheureusement le
père noël ne peut pas accueillir
chimiques espagnol mais c'est vrai qu'on
est là benoît elle serait jalouse
donc forcément mais avait entendu ton
veut n'a pas été exaucé mais tu
rencontres le père noël est père noël je
vous le redis c'est un grand honneur
pour moi de me trouver dans son cas la
version le père noël existe et il en
fait il ya ici une partie des pères noël
mais ce qui en fait à cette paire noël
en laponie et il en fait partie c'est un
des pères noël
il fait son métier il parle c'est quoi
qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il avait
dans la main dans la main comme libres
alors s'il avait dans la main là c'est
ça c'est les photos de famille s'il ya
toujours son album de passage avec
talent et non vivres des vhu et rigolo
parce que c'est les photos des enfants
ça et des bas mais vous avez quand je
voulais rencontrer juin alors que c'est
vrai quoi émouvant alors que l'émotion
tout le monde
tout le monde a beaucoup d'émotion